sébastien cette jeune fille résume
parfaitement la journée quand on lit le
communiqué de menaces
on arrive à la conclusion que c'est
probablement pas vrai parce que c'est
n'importe quoi
mais il faut prendre ça quand même au
sérieux puisque on a fait à québec
oui alors même si le communiqué vient de
groupes inconnus jusqu'ici même s'il est
dans un français approximatif tôt ce
matin la sûreté du québec a mis sur pied
ce qu'on appelle un poste de
commandement c'est à dire un centre de
coordination pour être en contact avec
la grc mais aussi avec les services de
police municipaux et alors donc aucun
effort n'a été ménagé pour s'assurer que
les écoles étaient sécuritaires
le gouvernement parle d'un geste
criminel voire même d'un acte terroriste
et il s'engage à poursuivre les auteurs
de ce courriel de menaces et on veut
s'assurer aussi que d'ici la fin de la
semaine toutes les écoles soient
sécuritaires
écoutons pierre moreau et premier
ministre philippe couillard il y aura
une vérité qui a été faire nous on prend
cette situation lors au sérieux on veut
rassurer la population veut dire à la
population que nous allons tout mettre
en oeuvre et aussi longtemps que nous
estimons qu'il y à une menace pour la
sécurité qu'elles soient appréhendés au
réel franchement les personnes
responsables de cet acte là quelle que
soit sa nature bien sûr une enquête doit
suivre son cours doivent savoir qu'elles
seront poursuivis alors dans le fil des
événements la sûreté du québec est mis
au courant vers 1h la nuit dernière
qu'il pourrait y avoir une menace sur
des écoles au québec mais on n'a pas le
détail et c'est au moment où les gens d
de l'administration de ces écoles entre
dans les écoles et découvre le courriel
que la le branle-bas est mise en place
et que les élèves sont évacués alors
pourquoi la sûreté du québec n'était pas
communiquer avec des écoles avant que
les le personnel administratif découvre
le courriel réponse commentaires et
explications du ministre par intérim de
la sécurité publique
la sûreté du québec a été mise en veille
d 1h10 pour suivre la situation lorsque
des établissements et d'hec des
établissements ont indiqué avoir reçu
l'information dans certains cas les
élèves étaient en déplacement il était
trop tôt on ferme pas toutes les écoles
du québec
sur toutes les menaces que la sûreté du
québec reçoit
alors la décision de rouvrir des écoles
qui ont été évacuées et fermées
aujourd'hui devrait être prise en
principe ce soir par le ministère de la
sécurité publique
conjointement avec le ministère de
l'éducation mais on comprend qu'il ait
plusieurs établissements qui ont déjà
ouvert notamment des cg très bien oui
merci à sébastien québec je vous en prie